[Music]
look how I I dropped his
hand and he stay there stay there you
see this
triangle you guys see that that's what
I'm trying to create if I put his hand
over here
I don't have that and that's that's
where I'm trying to go right so your
hand can't be here and his elbow can't
be straight down you have to turn it
Le in then I
turn and I keep that down you see it
it's going this way you guys see that
it's not going
here you want his shoulders down
[Music]
so the other hand is doing very much the
same thing not not here
here then let go we're on
this you see how is trying to throw the
same shoulder
[Music]
down so if I were to do like the C Net
right the exact same thing proba your
hand so you have one hand doing that the
other hand's doing the same thing aren't
they so they need to be symmetrical
I don't
swim so symmetrical
[Music]
okay so you got the two hands doing
their spiraling hand work you have
symmetry now you have to relate it to
your body so as you comes around I don't
step my body out and then
bow relate to your arm movement so my
arms are going this way and they're
going to go right under
me you guys see that
difference again
[Music]
no
here so I push
[Music]
w
this
[Music]
oh
oh for
[Music]
one
oh
[Music]
he
h
[Music]